you met me at the bar pretended to hit
on me and then you followed me all true
it's really I owe you what's it like
working with Amy you guys have a great
just onset dynamic she's been so sweet
Ryan to know they both kind of see that
same kind of thrive in each other and
are attracted to each other for that but
they want to keep us professional till
now well till a certain point maybe did
you know who she was going into this did
you have a crush on her at all I had no
clue who she was I don't really watch
that much TV I'm too busy trying to get
jobs what about on Piper she was in a
lot of stuff including coyote ugly
coyote ugly was the one for sure I
remember watching man I remember I I had
a crush on you pipes Ryan Guzman is one
of the stars of ABC's new show notorious
he plays a production assistant to a
news producer who finds ways to control
the media in real life Ryan's had to
shut down a few stories of his own I
think the craziest thing was the you
know the Jennifer Lopez stuff when I was
doing boy next door
it was just assumptions that we were
dating you know talking she's a friend
of mine and I I truly value for
friendship so so you never dated JLo no
no yeah we're good friends up and get
this when we asked him which co-star
makes for the better kisser he let a
little spoiler drop me hooking JLo is
hail well she marked me as her number
two best kisser so she's getting number
two
Jennifer but I think Amy Amy maybes up
there I think so you kiss Amy on the
show there's a kiss in there there's a
kiss in there there's a kiss
you